كشف المدعي العام للولايات المتحدة
ويليام بار
زيف مزاعم الرئيس ترامب بشأن
تزوير الانتخابات على نطاق واسع في مقابلة مع
الصحافة المرتبطة به ، كما قال ، اقتباسًا
حتى الآن ، لم نشهد تزويرًا على
نطاق كان يمكن أن يؤثر على
نتيجة مختلفة
في الانتخابات.  تريد إحضار
محلل قانوني CNN آن ميلجرام
والمحلل السياسي الكبير رون براونشتاين ليكون
معنا هنا
، وهذا بيان مهم صادر
عن المدعي العام ومن أحد
الموالين للرئيس
، إنه تصريح مهم
حقًا لقد  كانوا يتابعون القضايا المدنية
التي رفعتها الحملة ،
فقد خسروا 39 من تلك القضايا ،
وأعتقد أنهم ربحوا واحدة
وخسروا 39 قضية وتستمر المحاكم
في رفضها
مع الدائرة الثالثة مؤخرًا قائلة
إنه لا يكفي الادعاء بالاحتيال
أو مشكلة عليك أن تحضر بالفعل
إلى المحكمة وإثباتها
ولم يفعلوا ذلك ،
لذلك هناك جزء آخر من اللغز
وهو التحقيق الجنائي
نحن نعلم أن المدعي العام السابق
قد أخبر
المحامين ووكلاء مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالية أنه يمكنهم
التحقيق
إذا أرادوا أن يكون هذا
مخالفًا لسياسة doj طويلة الأمد
ولكننا الآن نخرجه
ويقول إنهم نظروا في بعض
الادعاءات المنهجية بالاحتيال  لم يعثروا على
أي شيء ، وأعتقد أن هذا
يدفعه كثيرًا إلى الاقتراب من جميع الدعاوى القضائية
التي يتم إجراؤها ، أعني أنه قال حتى الآن
ولكننا بعد شهر من الانتخابات
وأعتقد أنه إذا كان هناك أي شيء
سيأتي  قد يكون قد
رآها الآن